what is your advice to the people who  are afraid to talk about their mental  health i would say  everybody suffers from anxiety at some  point so  it's not as if you've done something  wrong if you're suffering mentally  there are things you should look into  like i would recommend looking into diet  if it's because you're stressed ideally  you can remove the stress from your life  if it's something that you can't control  then you just have to figure out how to  get through it  but it's not anything to be embarrassed  about and if you have people around who  care for you then  talk to them because they're going to  want to help you there's more awareness  of it  in the west and i know that there are  some cultures where you're kind of  insulted if you have some sort of mental  problem or bullied  but that's not because mental problems  aren't there it's because people aren't  talking about it